[Music]
well guys one of my most anticipated
games of the year has finally come out
The Last of Us is here I played it over
the weekend and I'm here to tell you
guys my thoughts on it you've seen it a
thousand times the video games zombies
around the corner they're everywhere I
like the Resident Evil games they're fun
but I was wondering what really about
this game is gonna set it apart from the
others you know what about the whole
survival horror thing is gonna make this
game special what's gonna make it
different I got to tell you The Last of
Us is hands-down one of the best games I
have ever played in my entire life I
loved every single second of this game
from opening to ending the Last of Us is
an enthralling experience that's not
just a game this game feels like a movie
the dialogue the acting the voice acting
the character models everything in this
game is like flawless I honestly cannot
find a single thing wrong with The Last
of Us it is one of the best games I've
ever played and by far the best game
I've played in years you play as Joel in
this game and he has been commandeered
to transport a little girl all around
this area and try to keep her safe now
I'm not gonna tell you what his goals
are I'm not gonna tell you what is going
on with this girl because I want you to
experience this game as it happens the
game opens with a terrific mission that
I won't spoil as well but it gives you a
great depth and a look at why Joel is
the way he is when you finally do get to
take control of him within like the
first half an hour of this game I was
almost crying I'm not even kidding like
this game truly emotionally affects you
because the dialogue is so fresh and the
voice acting is near-flawless and the
character animations are the best
character animations I've ever seen in a
game the way these characters acted the
way they ran the things that they did as
they encounter environments like when
you run as Joel if you run past a wall
he literally will start to take his
right hand and move alongside the wall
it's just it's all so well handled never
is a random sound effect out of place
never does a character have some kind of
interaction that looks strained I never
encountered a single glitch in the game
everything in this game was so well done
by Naughty Dog these guys are excellent
at drama they really encapsulated these
two characters in this game and made you
feel like you are there because it's so
common this whole survival Horrors
these guns it gets repetitive after a
while and I think they understood that
because although the combat in this game
is there it is limited because they take
the most time with a character
development in this game which made it
so much more important to me and made it
so much more entertaining as a game the
control feels seamless once you learn
where all the buttons are it just feels
like it's an extension of you nothing
and this game feels out of place the
graphics are terrific some of the best
I've ever seen the music is excellent
the entire feel and overall atmosphere
of the game is so good now I got to say
the one thing I haven't gotten to
explore that much is the multiplayer
because I spent basically the whole
weekend trying to beat the game so I
haven't really got to get that deep into
the multiplayer but from what I've heard
it is very good but I can't tell you
personally myself I apologize for that
The Last of Us is a game that I honestly
don't want to spoil anything else about
the graphics are terrific the story is
near flawless the voice acting excellent
the controls feel as if they're part of
your hands please if you have a
Playstation
check out the Last of Us it is one of
the best games I have ever played I'm
gonna give the last of us a 10 out of 10
my highest rating for a video game I
hope you guys do check it out if you
want to its I mean I honestly would say
it's worth the 60 bucks
I really would and that's not something
I say to you often because 60 bucks is a
lot of money you know I mean I even
rented it I don't want to spend 60 bucks
on a game unless I know it's good and
I'm telling you guys this game is
awesome check it out if you want to have
a good time thanks as always for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck man
eyes
[Music]